hello ladies and gentlemen welcome back
to the chord or digital podcast episode
119. it's a surprise every time for
everyone
for news as we just sourced for reliable
news based on only facts by people who
only study facts all day on global uh
socio-political economic issues
to our google drive yeah um i just
cleared 123 gigs off of jordan's cash
because they were all facts yeah they
call us the snowden effect but i'm so
hyped up right now because matt and i
were just playing speed checks my heart
rate is racing so i don't know if you
guys know this the tale um but so what
happened was uh
uh there's a smash tournament that goes
on multiple times a day yeah jake is
famously yeah against this and i'm
famously antisma and tishma
and so during the uh smash tournament i
purchased a chess table
um and i had that put in the main room
um so that anyone who didn't want to
smash could play chess
and um
matt and i were engaged in a very hyped
game of speed chess and we were
we're being audible about it yeah and uh
we got yelled at by the rest of the team
because we were being too loud in the
work area specifically the more vocal of
the smash players yeah one of the more
vocal of the smash players is very shut
up oh how the turn tables
turn
and now you know i just think
karma that's all i think yeah cause it's
like are you satisfied now
i i'm a little bit more satisfied than i
was yeah and i don't i didn't think that
i was seeking vengeance but apparently
in my heart i was
do you think chess was more hype back in
the day when that was like the only game
they had oh dude yeah hell yeah
i was also explaining this
i was also explaining the um
the oppressive nature of the chess board
to matt earlier today too because it's
based off of loosely off of like feudal
structure because you have the king and
queen in the middle
and then you have uh
what the bishops
who sort of tuck in the royalty right
the church tucking in the royalty and
protecting it on the inside and then of
course on the outside of the bishops you
have the knights the lowest members of
the noble class it's really progressive
and then the rooks on the outside the
castle and then the ponds in front of
course the cannon fodder
yeah
and the cannon fought up yeah is it how
is it progressive sam yeah aggressive
the queen is the most powerful character
on the map and when you look at feudal
society like that royalty courts
generally women weren't allowed in those
types of structures and uh yet here we
are chess well i think everyone has
known the truth since time immemorial
which is that you know the the man might
ha be the head but the woman is the neck
and the woman can turn the head any way
she wants true oh whatever what i'm
saying what a statement what a statement
what a great metaphor yeah analogy thank
you the title of this podcast
sure people have asked for like a
corridor chess set like 3d print one but
i'm like maybe we shouldn't go there you
know like maybe we shouldn't yeah i
categorize ourselves into this
oppressive yeah slash progressive yeah
i don't know what it is
the medieval kind of stuff you can
romanticize that a little bit you know
when you look at today's problems
through that romantic medieval nature
right you know i think i think things
get a little bit brighter you know
wealth inequality right becomes kind of
a little bit more fun though the simple
life of an indentured surf because it's
more working
when you make a game of it
yeah it's only funny because the
majority of the world is not living in a
futile society
that's the only reason why it's funny
yes yeah i petition you to raise my pay
from three pence to four a day
three to four are you mad
my god man that's like 25 percent
uh so anyway speed chess
i think it's a thing now i think we
should get a little ten second time
no we came up with it we just came up oh
yeah there's that little they're
that's true
well dang it would have been a great one
we'll just have to get another one yeah
we are going to get another one because
i need to use it for this next son of a
dungeon season oh okay every time
everyone doesn't move i'm like timer
it's like that's good
yeah yeah we should do that it's like
you talk for a half hour and then it's
like five seconds look i don't know if i
i don't know how you feel if i was one
of the deliberators talkers sort of like
slow players but from my perspective
it was primarily dee and nico who were
constantly debating what we should do
next yeah but we've we've touched upon
this in a previous podcast okay well one
day but yes you've cleared your name
okay so thanks thanks sam
yeah hey so spider-man weekend guys yeah
how about that spider-man weekend what a
doozy i'm ready to never think about
spider-man again i am so happy i hope
you are he's a good viewer yeah
hey
yeah i'm sure we've tired out all of
the entire debrief it's like three years
worth of spider-man yeah and like yeah
not only two crew videos two corridor
videos as well yeah yeah which is kind
of like one of which ended up happening
on trending which is great this is crazy
yeah that was planned by the way not
spiderman ended up 18 on trending yeah
it's pretty cool it's so funny
and we didn't even release that video at
the time we made it for fear that it
wasn't very good i mean if you watch the
video and you're like this is a video
i personally was like this is not i mean
it could it needed some work did it did
some work but the thing is it aged
so well yeah it aged
it's just so ripe it's yeah it was from
the private reserve cabinet of videos
that we keep you know unopened videos
that we're like we're gonna save this
for a special occasion it was like a two
dollar bitcoin we had in our wallet that
we forgot about yeah and now it's like
right because they create that time
right yeah it's just yeah yeah the
flavors you know they
they settled they mingled
i thought it was like whiskey where it
doesn't like get better with age you
know unless it's in the barrel but no
it's it's it's wine
well well maybe it was whiskey in a
barrel or wine wherever wine resides
in a bottle or in a barrel or in a
barrel yeah anyway metaphors aside i
wasn't here before this video for the
creation of this um whatever this is um
what what was the moment like because
i'm sure there was like a release date
right you're talking about not spying
not spiderman yeah why did it yeah there
was a release date right and you guys
had to like actually make a call i'll
just tell you i'm super straight up like
i was on paternity leave when they were
trying to finish it up and it was really
stressful like seeing this video and i
was like guys are you gonna like make
this better
and so i'm just like they're like
away from everyone and it's just like
guys please don't release this like if
you're if you're not gonna at least give
it that one extra level of like
okay you know making it settle i was
like please don't
let's let's let's uh yeah put this in
the barrel okay it was your call wasn't
it it wasn't the seller i i was i threw
a little baby fit about it the gustiest
gorsky wins it was it was his it was not
a very big fit it was more like it was
like
i don't think this is releasable right
now and then we
sent it out in the direction of the
bermuda triangle yeah and
it was lost beneath the sea
it was lost for years it was lost for
years until an archaeologist or a diver
found it
and popped that cork yeah
whose idea was it even to
bring it back out well it was because
when we were filming the uh
toby uh the uh what is it the andrew
garfield field debunk yeah yeah it came
up
so yeah
[Music]
well like spider-man
that sounds very did everyone made a
spider-man video it's like yeah it's
like no haven't we made two spider-man
videos we made three two there's so many
spider-man videos i made three
spider-man videos i did all the metadata
on the wrong spider-man video
last weekend
i did all the men i'm like [ __ ] this is
the wrong one wait this is
[Laughter]
oh vice versa
that's so funny my brain was just like
i was like peter's spider-man there was
so much spider-man so i can't i mean and
then the timing
for them to drop another trailer yeah on
the same day
or that right around the same day
was just the sort of i know the trailer
came out like i don't care about
spiderman i was like i'm not what i
didn't want to watch it's like
i like i love that
people are now about including the dash
what's the dash spider dash man
because
back when we did like the anatomically
correct spider-man and when we recorded
not spider-man the dash concern was not
in the in the public consciousness
and now if you release a thing without
the dash there's going to be multiple
commenters who
who tell you that the dash is necessary
yeah that's fine it's like a latinx wow
but the problem is the moment i start i
see the word spi i like my my brain
starts to click off
so i don't get far enough to finish
those kind of comments
that was like oh yeah
yeah no it's it's really every fandom
goes so deep and like people were
commenting like the most nitpicky stuff
and it's like guys
literally marvel's removed every bit of
stakes from their whole universe by
making infinite universes so why are you
getting hung up on one little continuity
because literally it's like oh thanos he
kills all the people and then they all
come back stakes removed let's just
let's take any bit of intensity out of
our holes
well they can't kill a main character
yeah no of course not then it's canon
even though i could just bring him back
in a different
row down his union's like
i'm done
but in one universe he's not so but a
one yeah they'll recast him and it'll
all be oh they'll recast him for sure i
mean i think it'd be hard to like
be the same character in a movie series
for like 13 years or whatever well the
line i think the line two between like
movies and television is so blurry now
when it comes to marvel yeah
i think in general though like it's a
it's that's a good thing though
yeah yeah that's a good thing it's also
the multiverse is kind of fun to explore
as like a third party because it's like
you can it's still it's kind of canon
like it's all sort of canon in a
multiverse they made it to canon they
made everything everything's canon now
if you precisely you just say it's well
it's in an alternative multiverse that's
good or like the the the craze right now
yeah the best in multiverses right yeah
multiple like they're doing it for
wonder woman
they did it in like that one division
show briefly with the uh that
quicksilver actor uh they're doing it in
spider-man they're doing i mean
people just go crazy yeah
over actors being characters working
together they're like dude like let's
mix this yeah
where did it start i feel like it's rick
and morty really started it to a point
where it's like oh now now the general
audience understands multiverses i think
star trek technically started it yeah
yeah right right or i mean for me did
they have like crossover episodes in
star trek where they had like
like different
like characters from well it was just
the idea of like all right we have all
these star trek shows but then the
characters from these different like
enterprises or space stations then have
like a crossover episode where it's like
you're like whoa like it's it's not
technically multiverse you know but it's
like that concept of
these are two separate shows and then
we're gonna have the characters
you know like there's still canon in the
same universe
and yeah i don't know like but it's
that's that's all it's just like pure
fan service but but the thing is it
works oh yeah you're like whoa my eyes
my mind just got opened mm-hmm
yeah
we should discuss whether or not this is
a good or a bad thing i just think it's
a horrible thing for any stakes in this
story like i can never watch another
superhero movie now and feel anything
because it's like well
if if everyone dies then there's a
universe where they didn't die so well i
think the point kind of ruins it
is to make a story that's not like
dependent on whether everyone dies or
not
well yeah i mean i'm sure you can find
superhero movies where that isn't but
but that like that's the really
important thing though like that is the
rick and morty part of it which is like
okay sure there's infinite ricks and
mortys there's infinite multiverses yet
still they manage to have a compelling
story for each episode i think the way
they accomplish that is by having
central characters that are the only
ones of their kind and that that rings
true with the marvel multiverse too
where it's like the rick and morty world
there's only one like you know rick in
one one
like
they actually died and came back
multiple times yeah maybe yeah like i
just i remember seeing an episode
recently that like in the fourth season
that is like i was like i lost track of
like which one was the
real one yeah i don't know yeah
if you've been watching this podcast for
a while you already know what time it is
it's time for me to tell you about
today's sponsor story blocks but let's
cut a little bit deeper let's flip it
over to the b side because you know i
usually tell you about how storyblocks
is your one-stop shop for all your stock
asset needs for creators and businesses
alike and how they have high quality 4k
b-roll images audio motion graphics
after effects templates and more but
what does that mean really what it means
really for us
is it means that when we need something
to glue videos together
we just go to story blocks and we
download what we need from there and i
can't express to you how important it is
to have a tool like this if you're
serious about creating videos carmichael
and nick used to go out and get b-roll
for the early vlogs this was pre-story
blocks and they used to go out and it
would take them like a long time because
you gotta you gotta get the shots and
that just takes time and what you wanna
do is put more time into the thing that
makes your video original and stand out
and utilize story blocks to fill in the
gaps where you just need to have an
image to explain something or you just
need a template to do something quickly
that's what we use it for it's a great
tool they have a virtually unlimited
library as you guys probably already
know meaning that you're always going to
find something new there it's constantly
being updated they have an unlimited
all-access plan which is the plan that
we use they also have enterprise plans
for teams under either one of those
plans you can download as much as you
want use it however you want and then
move on with your day that's what i want
to tell you guys about it's a great tool
they're a huge sponsor to this podcast
and they're going to be sponsoring
corridor crew next year so i'm very
excited about that i can't wait to just
get the word out to a larger audience
but anyway you're a troton so you
already know so if you're interested in
getting story blocks for yourself head
on over to storyblocks.com
cord or cast and get signed up over
there that's
storyblocks.com
chord or cast now back to the podcast i
agree with nick
it ruins it for me okay without like the
risk of i mean they're superheroes
they're fighting bad guys from other
ethereal planes
and other
places of existence that come to earth
for all sorts of nefarious purposes
and then they're supposed to defend
earth right they're they're like the
best ideals of ourselves and there's but
there's no risk of death it's like
what what do you mean then i ask a
question to you uh
would
the existence of multiple dimensions
ruin your current life
yes i mean yes
that would [ __ ] us all up that would
destroy anyone's only reality
so like what is that a stephen hawking
thing right where it's like hey there's
multiple multiple dimensions i'm sure
there are but we can't access them okay
so but okay so until you can access them
like once you can access the multiverse
life
meaningless i don't sleep easy at night
no okay you know if i
if i jumped off a bridge tomorrow i'd
just be okay in another multiverse yeah
but that's different though because
that's a different you still like from
an audience's perspective spider-man can
die
as long as like toby mcguire still also
what what
outside of like
you know the theory of alternate
universes like the the
truth of them is like what we don't know
so
that's that's more like well actually to
think about it physically in a funnier
way multiverse life doesn't matter well
if there's multiverses and multi
multiple dimensions um
it's like as as a viewer of those
multiple dimensions all those other
lives don't matter except yours
and it's the same for everyone so it's
like
i'm like jake your life doesn't matter
because there's a million there's a
million me
and then you're like no i'm still me
but you sam there's a million other
years so you're you know so it's like
it's all just like a super selfish
like perspective on everything
do you think they do that in the movies
they should in the marvel movies maybe
nothing matters in life or in the
multiverse he's like yeah spider-man's
our life maybe it's actually like no i'm
the real spider-man
so it's like narcissistic and nihilistic
all at the same time yeah it kind of is
kind of would be that's sad it is what
do you think spider-man feels when he
sees like 20 other spider-men like is he
like i'm worthless now because like
whose life yes whose life shall i
replace precisely
it's like what makes missus that's the
point of the trailer it's like his life
gets messed up by doctor strange so he
has to go take over
uh andrew garfield's movie franchise and
make it better
i really hope they stay accomplished
thanks for explaining that
[Laughter]
i don't know i wonder how much pressure
the writers are under to like write on a
very specific thing who's actually
riding this
um a very large panel a panel of judges
multiple people probably like with
to think about that like
imagine that right imagine that quote
writing process because like all these
disney and marvel films are like okay so
yeah you have a script but then there's
like a million people who review it
and then then there's like storyboards
and like video boards and previews
you basically make the movie before it's
made and then
you review that and then a bunch of
producers and the writers and directors
all review that and then you film it and
then you show it to people and then you
film it again you reshoot right half of
the movie yeah until so you have this
like crazy amount of iteration to create
this like
it's like
it's pristine you know
do you think they pair every writer with
a lawyer oh my god
all right guys you guys go write the
next spider-man movie we got uh one
month um
there's just a lawyer that stands over
them because there's so much there's so
much well not only like canon that they
well i guess it doesn't matter now if
they change [ __ ] because they're
multiverses so hey [ __ ] who cares but
there's so much like legal boundaries
and like overstepping that has to be
accounted for
they must have like lawyers write these
things do you think we can just like
throw it all out and then start with new
characters no
no
no we're banking on that nostalgia bro
man it's all decades
well yeah that's enough superheroes that
invented what 60 years ago yeah they're
the only ones right okay those are the
only ones
yeah we're gonna find the most obscure
superheroes
right we're gonna make a movie about it
yeah the nostalgia is so profitable
though too it's the thing it's like i
mean you do the norse guys they came up
with thousands of years ago that they're
still like worshipping isn't that funny
they should be we could be creating like
new pantheons of deities
like you talk about every year there's a
new pantheon to warship like norse gods
right you got thor you got loki you know
i'm sorry i'm just making it you got the
whole thing
but like those it's it's just like
we took all these principles from like
our own existence and then we were like
what if we just like
put a mirror between or like a pane of
glass between like where we actually get
these stories and these ideals about
these characters and we'll just like
tint it this way and then people will
like it again right that's why
spider-man's cool cause it's not
appropriating any culture but spiders
okay
[Laughter]
like anything about anything appropriate
[Laughter]
very true oh man
anyway look i don't mean to be salty i
don't
look it's not my cup of tea but everyone
loves it so that's good you're one of
those like quotes i'm glad that people
watch it
it's like it keeps it's well known
superhero movies suck
no man i just wish there were more like
actual
big budget movies being made these days
with original ideas everything's
rebooted i loved dune i loved it but
it's also a reboot and it's been done so
many times already yeah and it's like
no one's willing to put big they're too
expensive now i know that's the problem
they're cheaper than ever in a way
because you can do so much digitally and
it's like i feel like there's no excuse
not to be
putting into movies what everyone's
putting into like these series that get
watched well let's let's talk about this
for a second because this is important
and i don't think a lot of people know
this but there are
big studio movies
and those are sort of in a category of
their own when it comes to the scale the
cost how they're made who's involved how
they get written how they get
distributed all that stuff and those are
like the 100 million plus
you know films and but my when i was
saying like they're too expensive it's
it's like
when you're only releasing
you know five of those a year
like
you you
one of those is 20 to 25
of your
budget for the year and if it doesn't if
it like you can literally as a studio
executive you can literally bankrupt
the entirety of warner brothers the
entirety of disney well not the entirety
of disney but a substantial portion of
the entire business can be sunk
on like a couple bad films
that's how expensive these things are
and so they can't take any risk but yeah
the thing that's the thing that was like
there are like i was reading an article
that actually was addressing this
specific subject where they're going hey
actually you know we're complaining
about original ip and theaters and
filmmaking and it kind of points out oh
hey by the way check out this all those
streaming services like amazon prime and
netflix and stuff they are technically
doing that right now like what was it
that one wacky one we saw with the
little there's a ton of original stuff
you know
with uh
chris pratt what is it called forever
tara morrow war yeah
you know it's like technically that's an
original ip you know and like these
streaming services
yeah well they are so but like they're
not like the you know 200 mil kind of
things but it's like they're technically
happening it's just that they suck
you know so just to get to get them just
to piggyback on that for a second like
why doesn't that why wasn't the tomorrow
why does it hit the same vein if it's
other than because it's not a great
script
good question i think it's just because
it's not hyped up enough
and it's not presented in a way i think
it's a hybrid there's a couple things
you don't it's not like you're watching
it's not it's not a national
distribution in the theater there's not
a classic two-week prior ad campaign
that splashes everything both on
physical billboards television
digital ads campaign no no i'm saying
this entirely
mcdonald's
that machine only that machine used to
operate like at all levels of filmmaking
yeah depending on how successful the
film was now that machine only operates
at that highest level of studio
production and everything else under 100
million dollars that's all been moved
over to digital yeah now yeah and
netflix isn't gonna waste money to do a
billboard ad campaign although they do
them in los angeles still but that's
only because there's industry people
here
they don't they're not gonna splash like
every freaking
platform they can do
on marketing i'm not going to say they
should either i'm just saying like it's
like the it it still is it's technically
happening but yeah i want to say like
it's hard to boil down my i guess grapes
but like
you just want better movies when i say
the hype no when i say the hype though
it's like
you don't see hype over original ips
like you do over superheroes i would
argue that something like squid games
insanely hyped yes it's actually the
most effective kind of advertising was
that word of mouth like social media
advertisement of squid games that like
was like so effective to get the thing
you know yeah sure insanely popular
that's not like a studio film like
foreign like that was a
diamond of the rough for sure yeah i
agree it's also kind of a rehash of
battle royale but we won't go there i
mean is that is anything not a rehash of
something else no i mean that's
alterations
like
you don't see risks as many risks being
taken because yeah like one bad movie
can bankrupt your studio or two yeah but
they would take enough risks to
diversify that so that they'd also have
some bangers and that would make them a
lot of profit so that's just not how
they're built anymore i know and so but
the nice thing is is that the streaming
platforms have taken over that role
of course yeah but it's now quantity
over quality i think oh totally
totally is
but that was kind of the game before
before the digital era came to b2 like
you had a bunch of movies that were
mid-budget movies you know from the 15
to like 80 million dollar films that
were being
dozens and dozens of those were being
produced every year and they would do
some of them would take off some of them
wouldn't i mean that's been the same i
think the low budget horror movie genre
is still very much well yeah i mean the
low budget horror though again is is in
its own class yeah of film yeah it's
like
and you don't always sell they will
because well because you make them for
cheap enough if you make it for 500 000
and it sells for 5 million then you just
made you know
[Music]
ten times your money yeah so
yeah um
but
i think the point remains you know which
is that
there's not uh
in the in the there's no risk being
taken and that just sort of
who knows how long that'll last i don't
know
it's like the only original content
being made
is for people that are captive audiences
already it's like yeah oh we have a
billion subscribers cool we'll make them
content but right we know we're gonna
get clicks probably on it you know and
if we don't then we won't renew the
season everyone will move on to the next
thing we give them
yes and then we'll reboot and very
obscure comments a little bit of that is
just the game i know of course it is and
i understand that we make vfx artists
react every week too you know but if we
also if it didn't perform well we would
stop making it yeah like hundred percent
we wouldn't just make it into i know
that's the game i'm not saying like oh
we need these authors to only make the
finest films
and like i know this is a common thing
that people say
really i'm just [ __ ] tired of people
going around superhero costumes
that's what it boils down to well yeah
they're just gonna be in some other
costume if it's not superheroes true i
mean like chris pratt and some tech gear
fighting aliens look nick you can't you
can't this is going to sound good is
that guardians of the galaxy or wasn't
that a tomorrow
oh yeah sorry this is going to sound
pessimistic of me yeah but you can't
blame
you know if you look at
the brainless society as a whole like
you can't blame it for being such at the
same time like
and i'm not talking about anyone
individually i just mean like
there will always be an element of
society that's just like remember when
you were 12 and it was like abercrombie
and fitch was cool and you just wanted
abercrombie and fitch just so that you
could be like everybody else like it's
about that's that will never go away you
know for sure man look hype there's hype
and i'm
i totally get it people need heroes
people need heroes people need heroes
more than ever this is now more than
ever
this is what they tell themselves though
in times like these yeah these trying
times oh dude people need to hear there
is definitely
people that are in these rooms that are
making decisions on these films that are
saying that and believing it no they do
and it's paying off for them they're
like yeah
heroes
let's go they needed heroes yeah
see all this money we're gonna give them
heroes goddamn it that's why i love the
boys man it's just yeah it sums it all
up yeah yeah yeah that's true
shout out it's more you know what
bothers me more than i guess you see the
new spider man what what bothers me more
than the films is that perspective
what bothers me more than this
is the perspective of like
we know what you need
let us
let us
tell you how you're gonna be
what if i told you that making movies
was really hard
yes and the reason there's not as all
these sweet original movies is because
there's not a lot of people to make them
and it's hard to do it yeah and they'd
much rather make a reboot of something
they know they can make decently than
coming up with something from scratch
that's well we know that totally valid
yeah yeah so that's that's why i'm like
i don't know like i can only dunk on
marvel so much
because it's like they're winning so any
dunking we do is uh very irrelevant but
they're like they're killing the game
did you see that corridor cast yeah with
all 12 people watching it
thank you all 12 of you no look
appreciate it it's great
dune was great i'll take a fresh fresh
course baby i'll take a fresh one i
brought my bushel straight from the
river oh look at you sir um no i'm all
right i don't mean to be pessimistic
let me let me pose this question
to you folks um does originality is
originality synonymous with
uh characters that you are familiar with
it's inherently not
right
yeah
originality at its core of the word that
you're using like origin original cannot
also be familiar it can't be familiar
right well i think to it to a certain
extent
it cannot be but
thanks
but in order for it to be relatable oh
yeah i'll take one
like if i just made up gibberish words
can you make yeah
can you still make an array can you
still tell an original story
while using
characters we're familiar with well so
there's a yes
personally there's a couple things about
that one you can't tell an original
story like not holistically
it's impossible because everything about
stripped down everything about your
human experience is like a story
but
more generally i think you can tell an
original story without it
yeah yeah but there's need to be there
need to be things about it that like
people can understand
otherwise it won't otherwise it's just
gibberish what's the best movie you saw
this year
that's a good question
man um it might be
you know i've been watching some old
john wayne movies
some of them are actually pretty good
some of them are not some of them are
not but there's this one where he goes
to ireland
to like i forget what it's called the
silent man
and uh he goes to ireland to like
because his family died or whatever and
he goes to ireland to like reconnect
with his roots and it's pretty good it's
not bad
i watched the uh the like hd
blade runner they just put on the
director's cut or whatever
and that was the first time i'd actually
watched that movie all the way back and
that was [ __ ] amazing
compared to dune
compared to i mean
dune was also really amazing and what
did you enjoy
more
like what what what what got you more
excited and like got you more like
involved
i think blade runner okay just because
everything was like
so textural and yeah rich it's so rich
and it
i mean dune yeah it's like that's a
movie that can only be achieved today
but blade runner looks like a movie that
could be achieved today but it was made
like so many i think blade runner also
has it technically a better story than
dealing but it holds up i also
personally there was something about
blade runner 2049 that like i didn't
like
it not this is no slide against how much
incredible art artistry went into it i i
do not mean that at all i mean it was
like
it was so unfettered that it was almost
like a stanley kubrick movie where it
was like he'll just focus on a shot for
way too long and you're like
yo why am i still watching this shot you
know they're like
look i love the movie but like the first
15 minutes i freaking hate 2049 yeah
just like long shots of him standing in
this empty house like creaky floors like
i get it he's alone
can we move on
amazing after that but i was just like
come on right yeah come on it's like
this old engine of like this beautiful
car
that you're just like
but once it's going
it's great yeah and honestly they won
because that got that emotional reaction
out of me and then all of a sudden i'm
sitting there like watching it waiting
for the next shot like what the [ __ ] is
going to happen you know waiting for it
to come they got me they got me good
i tried to watch dunes three times and
every time i try to watch it on hbo max
it won't load oh and i've tried
restarting streaming
reinstalling the app
so if you think quarter digital is jank
just just know that hbo max isn't doing
my personal problem you're in review
matt year in review
oh man best film goes too well my friend
i have to say dune is an incredible
movie
however something that really captured
my attention
is pig
nicholas cage
it's really it's it's a movie that's
like very simply told but told it so
efficiently
uh i'm a big fan of it definitely i
recommend anyone watching
it's a fun one it's like john wick with
the pig
not really okay
that's an original story
that's how you come up with original
i think of stuff
like that but like yeah i was like right
in the kitchen there's a pig
it is nick cage and a pig like dude are
they friends jonathan
isn't he a truffle hunter who like falls
on hard times yeah
it's literally just an exploration of a
character and it's it's really well done
dude i'm going to try to get out those
are my jams yeah i like that that's a
real fun one yeah in in a really
soul-crushing kind of way yeah yeah well
it's kind of gotta be if it's gonna draw
you in yeah nick cage what a national
treasure
honestly yeah like yeah when he's hit
are you being punny or no no he's great
like yes
he's just oh what a gym like when
i love the movies that you just see on
netflix that have his face on the on the
cover and you're like i know nick cage
is gonna be this in this for five
minutes they got him for five minutes
yeah those are the best movies to watch
and just fast forward till you see him
and he phones it in every time
he he is one of those national treasures
and
like
just to talk about alec baldwin for a
second oh let's do it oh god here we go
he has he is also becoming his own
national treasure he had the audacity
to say that he didn't pull the trigger
oh he went and did an interview
after this
it seemed very bad did you did you pull
the trigger and he was like no no no no
no no no
it's not your fault there's no
intentional harm done like you you you
didn't you didn't have the bad mind to
like commit the crime
it's a mistake it's a it's a it's a it's
not like it matters it's a tragedy
like someone gives you a [ __ ] stack
of dynamite and it blows up and like did
you
push the plunger
[Laughter]
it's like it doesn't matter anymore
legit had the audacity that you think
like you're such in your own world that
you think human beings are so
fundamentally stupid that they don't
know
that it could just like go it can't just
go off yeah they made a whole like what
is it like an hour long freaking
interview with you yeah i couldn't watch
it which which felt like i just watched
the first like minute of it and like
they had like a little sizzle reel at
the beginning and it showed like alec
baldwin crying and stuff and just like
all of like this
is like
literally
propaganda to like seriously absolve him
yeah seriously emotionally all i imagine
is ari gold from honorary calling up
what's his name be like yeah okay we
gotta get you soon like right off the
plane you're gonna do this 60 minutes
special how do you think they get those
ideas because that stuff happens at the
end of the day he's a producer of the
propaganda he's a producer on the film
and he should take responsibility for it
that's my thing and look it's there is
no crime done not by him anyway
it's like there was a bad round in there
how it got in there you know
is is there's
is a whole separate thing but in terms
of your culpability legally like you you
did nothing wrong so why don't you just
say like
look i was handed this i
did what i was supposed to do in the
scene and it was an incredible tragedy
and an accident and that's it no one's
gonna be like yeah but
and if they do then clearly they're not
even somebody who can have a rational
thought about this whole situation so
then their opinion doesn't matter it's
crazy how much it's being politicized
you know oh my god alan baldwin or alec
baldwin liberal who hates guns and you
shoot you know everyone's using it's
just on both sides
and then on the other side of the tools
to tool yeah dude on the other side it's
like shameful oh we can never use any
pyrotechnics on set anymore right sam is
someone who's worked with pyrotechnics
i'm interested to hear your
opinion of that like do you think we
should just stop using them entirely and
go to the affection
everyone's a [ __ ] idiot
the george carlin quote what was that i
keep reading it he's popping up which is
like imagine how stupid the average
person is and then realize that
there's like half of the people in the
entire world that are stupider than them
like
the whole that's true pessimism right
there yeah that's true no but like i
don't give it's stupid like whatever
someone died
right whatever like it's sad yeah
don't do it again right
i don't i don't know what to say
you don't have to say so many dangerous
things in the world yeah it's just like
don't have cars on set right how about
that let's start there let's start there
cars probably injure way more people
than oh man cameras are way more cameras
injure and kill
everything but i just it's mostly
because i'm just fed up with listening
to politicians in general and then also
everyone like
i mean but here's the thing it's over
like we're talking about it everyone had
their like moment on twitter where
they're saying we
we are never using
blank firing weapons yes on our set
again visual effects only and now we win
it's like
look they're gonna get those effect
shots back and be like [ __ ] dude we
should have just done that we should
have done it have people not realize
that about twitter i think the situation
with him
are they really not people's opinion on
whether they should be using whatever
they want to do on set it's the only
thing it should
influence is people's opinions on who
who they have on their set
that's really what it comes down to
because there's gonna be dangerous
things that happen on sets every day
and you just wanna make sure there's the
right person
you know in control of that situation
what you want to hire an old frickin
dude who can't pull someone's weight on
a road for a while
because they'll drop them right
what bothers me what bothers me about it
and with the whole thing that you were
saying nick which is just like everyone
tries to take a bite at the you know
everyone wants their pound of flesh from
the tragedy and and every time something
like this happens it becomes something
where
everyone goes into their shams about
what how how everybody should act based
on one freaking thing
that is just another inherent danger
from a particular type of of industry
and it's just it's just like yo
why why do we got to do that i don't
know and how many you know how many
people have been fired on set or
explosions put off on michael bay movies
or whatever that have gone off without a
hit yeah well there's been a lot of
injuries you sat there
to sit there and see it and go oh yeah
yeah there's a few likes too with blank
frank guns all the time not the first
one yeah i mean everyone's going to the
last one
it wasn't even blank fire it's just
crazy yeah it was an actual round
to the point of like in the last 30
years film set has films at deaths have
been because they learn from that varied
than that that brandon lee thing people
i hear that quoted every time i have a
gun on a set
or even a little toy airsoft gun
someone's talking about hey did you know
this fact it's like boromir aragorn
kicking the helmet on lord of the rings
everyone has that fact in their pocket
what is this darth sidious or whatever
that story it's like have you heard the
tales you learn from those horrible
tragedies and this is going to be
hopefully another case of learning from
this horrible tragedy and making sure
these professionals get hired not these
you know amateurs that are hired by the
producers last minute
who uh
then lead to this well i don't know how
they just just so we're clear i don't
know how the rest of the investigation
has gone but in terms of when that
happened the the situation was that it
was a it was not a prop weapon that was
on set and it was brought out and it was
used just for firing and then a lot a
round was left in it that's what
happened as far as i know which is like
but it doesn't matter because you take a
real gun with a freaking blocked barrel
and a quarter load or whatever it
doesn't matter you still aim that
someone can still kill it doesn't matt
it doesn't matter the technical details
of how it went wrong the point is that
he could go wrong no matter
in a million similar situations too so
it's like it's the same thing as saying
did you know that if i lifted up a
80-pound camera on a rig and then
dropped it on a man he might die yeah
and then he'd be like well technically
it was a 90-pound camera and it's like
doesn't matter right
right the point is you point it at
someone and it goes off well i just the
end i just think yeah those are the
technical details i know you're i know
you don't want to talk in a direction so
we can move on from
you don't have to be this triggered
about it you just need to expect this
from people and then it'll be a lot
easier it's it's just sad it's that's
that's why i'm angry yeah it's very sad
yeah
yeah
f in chat
hopefully it's a learning experience
though i mean
this will be the new thing that is
quoted around all guns and i think sets
will be a lot safer for it so there's a
silver lining to this tragedy um yeah
so
yeah
in other news how did we get on that oh
nicholas cage nicholas yes it all
circles back to nicholas
i mean what's he going to do next who's
never killed the man with a gun what are
you wait can we just hypothesize on that
for a second what do you think nick cage
is going to do next
dude buy some more wacky outfits
probably he sold his house didn't he he
had to sell that which one
he had a castle at one point
he's a collector for sure
i give him props though dude like he's
he's living it up
how do you be that irresponsible with
money it's almost like a talent
i don't know
like
a movie industry if the movie company
pays you 10
million dollars to be in a film
right so okay the government's going to
tax you right so you're left over stream
lifestyle
you're you're like
six and a half all literally all you do
is put that in a stock tracking account
and the interest alone is enough to live
very wealthily off of for the rest of
your life yeah yeah but if you're saving
the right amounts
and not spending it like you're making
10 million a year spending five mil it's
like i just don't know you go like two
to three years without making life
increases and then you want to fuel the
fire
oh my god like how do you even enjoy it
anymore like what does that even mean
like you are you going on dives to find
those old balls that you've been talking
about yeah
are you going down to find those bottles
of not spiderman
he's the one who found it it's just is
that all you can drink anymore it's the
big spider ship
oh man
that's probably is all you can drink
anyway you're right that's that's
exactly that i've never thought about it
that way what did you call it lifestyle
lifestyle creep like it even happens
here even happens here
i just remember the first time jordan
brought all the snacks in oh yeah
nico was like
nika was like oh you know this is the
kind of lifestyle i can get into
[Applause]
he's looking at all these pop-tarts
[Laughter]
by the way we have corn dogs now yeah no
see look at this is what i'm saying
i
you know
he's having a snack
he brought some corn
[Laughter]
can we get a manufacturer
you're right you made the point we're no
better yeah we're no better
damn yeah well quality of life you know
i mean it's it's better than working in
95 degree temperatures like we used to
oh my gosh yeah you see
like we have the the humble beginning
air conditioning
2021 ace fully functioning ac corn dogs
what's next you want to laugh at that
you want to laugh at that i had to beg
borrow and steal to get that freaking
air conditioner put in and that was in
2016 yeah when we got that thing and
then this one
when we got this one
nika was like yo we're we're not even
gonna like be in that room that much do
we need an air conditioner in there and
i was like
bro
the first podcast was so hard
they were so hot
i was like why does everyone sweat isn't
there an air conditioner in here
yeah we've been living the like no ac
roughing it life for so long
you know it must have been kind of a
pride thing you know like dude almost
you know you're weak yeah
soft you're getting soft and draft
i just got yelled at for playing chess
yeah yeah true for playing chess too
loud
that's the funniest thing ever you
played chess too loudly
oh god he's pretty hyped though
oh man
wow
wow
look it's only up from here guys still
the corn dogs are not the peak i think
we can i think i feel like at least like
air conditioning and like maybe some
freezer corn dogs that's like pretty
normal
that's not 100 000 a month on wine you
know
no
so at least we got that and at least we
haven't
we're not on like a full keurig cup no
the k-cup system yeah we're on pour over
yeah it's over
right now it's all the rage though so
that's the thing
you know the k-cup thing once we hit
that point i know dude
my wife keeps asking me to get one and
i'm like
we got a pour over and a drip why do we
need a k-cup
as well it's not so superfluous no it's
not it's just way more expensive and
it's worse yeah and it's worse it's
worse and it doesn't work half the time
like why won't you go right it's like
i'm doing everything correctly
[Laughter]
together
[Laughter]
you grind the bean
you put the water through the bean and
it goes into the base yeah the craft and
that's it and you drink it it's it and
it's good yeah it is good why do we got
to mess it up
we don't got to mess it up no that's how
we do it we don't touch the coffee all
right well here's to not messing it up
this is the 2022 let's see the new
changes are coming
let's see the freezer upgrades we'll
check in with you we're going to have a
personal chef in the kitchen just yeah
what you want what you want
cooking up some beef wellingtons and
we're gonna
we're to create a algorithm
based off of your discord chats perfect
that will uh select a wine pairing for
you
wait i just realized that beef
wellington is the ultimate corn dog
it's the fanciest
[Laughter]
wow what a cast everyone yeah this was
they're as high as lows
and uh now come on sit in my spot and
talk about how much you like superhero
movies
it'll all balance itself out let's do
that let's let's let's pitch him and say
dean how much do you like stupid next
time on quarters next time on quarter
cass turns out we're actually shooting
two casts back to back
get ready for part two coming up soon